>> Jon: WELCOME TO THE DAILY
SHOW, MY NAME IS JON
STEWART.
WE GOT A PROGRAM FOR YOU
TONIGHT.
THIS IS-- THIS IS EXCITING,
ANNA KENDRICK, OH SHE'S ONE
OF OUR FAVORITES, SHE IS SO
GOOD. "INTO THE WOODS",
SHE IS GOING TO BE HERE, VERY
TALENTED.
BUT FIRST, YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
NOTICING THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM'S RECENT
CONSISTENT FAILURE TO INDICT
POLICE OFFICERS WHO HAVE
KILLED UNARMED BLACK MEN
HAS SPARKED PROTESTS ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
THE DEMONSTRATIONS HAVE
BEEN OVERWHELMINGLY
PEACEFUL.
WHICH MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR PEOPLE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
THEM.
DIFFICULT, NOT IMPOSSIBLE.
>> WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST, THEY GO ON THE
SIDEWALK AND MAKE NOISE AND
HOLD SIGNS AN LET PEOPLE
KNOW YOU DISAGREE.
BUT WHEN YOU BLOCK TRAFFIC,
THAT'S A FORM OF VIOLENCE.
>> Jon: YES!
THANK YOU, BLOCKING TRAFFIC
IS A FORM OF VIOLENCE.
HOW DARE THESE MARCHERS PUT
OUR STREETS IN SOME KIND
OF-- LET'S CALL IT A
CHOKEHOLD OF TRAFFIC.
HOW DARE THEY!
WOULDN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH THE STREETS BEING
BLACK, NOW, DOES IT?
YOU KNOW, IF YOU ARE THAT
CONVINCED THAT IMPEDING
MANHATTAN DRIVERS IS A FORM
OF VIOLENCE, WELL, I THINK IT'S
TIME TO INDICT THE NEW YORK
MARATHON.
THE MACY'S THANKSGIVING DAY
PARADE, THE PUERTO RICAN DAY
PARADE, THE GAY PRIDE PARADE,
THE ST. PATRICK'S DAY PARADE,
THE HALLOWEEN PARADE, THE GERMAN
AMERICAN STEUBEN PARADE OR ANY
RANDOM POP-UP STREET FAIR
SELLING MYSTERY MEATS AND
TUBE SOCKS, AND I HAVEN'T
EVEN GOTTEN TO THE MOST
VIOLENT OF OFFENDERS.
PLEASE, THAT TREE IS LIKE A
GLITTERING BERLIN WALL
PREVENTING ANY MOVEMENT FROM
EAST TO WEST.
MR. CLAUS, TEAR DOWN THAT
TREE.
(APPLAUSE)
BUT IT'S ONE THING FOR
PROTESTORS, IT'S ONE THING
FOR PROTESTORS TO DO
VIOLENCE TO OUR CITY STREETS
AND TRAFFIC.
IT IS QUITE ANOTHER FOR THEM
TO USE EXCESSIVE FORCE
AGAINST CHRISTMAS ITSELF.
>> IT IS CREATING HAVOC.
AND WE'VE GOT TWO WEEKS BEFORE
CHRISTMAS.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING
TO HAVE SOME IMPACT-- I MEAN
WHO WANTS TO GO SHOPPING AT
MACY'S WHEN THIS IS GOING ON.
>> Jon: PROTESTORS PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM SHOPPING AT MACY'S.
I HOPE THESE SHOPPERS SHALL
OVERCOME.
NOW THAT'S-- YES, I CAN'T
BUY-- YES, YES, BLACK FRIDAY
MATTERS.
IT DOES.
THE PROTESTS HAVE EVEN
SPILLED OVER INTO
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS.
>> ATHLETES DONNING T-SHIRTS
EXPRESSING A DESIRE FOR
JUSTICE.
NOW LAST TIME I CHECKED,
T-SHIRTS DON'T BLOCK
TRAFFIC.
THEY DON'T PREVENT FROM YOU
SHOPPING AT MACY'S.
THEY SHOULD BE A PERFECTLY
ACCEPTABLE WAY TO EXPRESS
ONE'S FEELINGS ABOUT
POLITICAL ISSUES.
>> I WONDERED TO MYSELF,
WHAT IF LEBRON JAMES INSTEAD
HAD A SHIRT BE A BETTER
FATHER TO YOUR DAD.
I MEAN BE A BETTER FATHER TO
YOUR SON.
RAISE YOUR CHILDREN.
THOSE DIFFICULT ISSUES ARE
NOT BEING DEALT WITH BY THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
>> Jon: WELL, BE A BETTER
FATHER.
LEBRON ACTUALLY LIVES THAT
MESSAGE.
AND IF HE WANTS ADVICE ON
SHIRTS I'M SURE HE WILL ASK
SOMEONE WHO WEARS ONE.
BUT POINT TAKEN.
POINT TAKEN-- NO, NOW-- WE
HAVE TO RESPECT THE POINT.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY ONE OF
THESE TWO MEN HAS FIVE KIDS
IN VARIOUS LOCATIONS BY
MULTIPLE BABY MOMMAS.
AND THE OTHER IS LEBRON
JAMES.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, GERALDO ISN'T
THE ONLY ONE UPSET ABOUT
THE T-SHIRT PROTESTS.
>> THE CLEVELAND POLICE
UNION DEMANDS AN APOLOGY
FROM THE CLEVELAND BROWNS.
ONE OF THE BROWNS PLAYERS
ANDREW HAWKINS WALKED ONTO
THE FIELD ON SUNDAY WEARING
THIS T-SHIRT.
IT CALLED FOR JUSTICE FOR
TAMIR RICE.
THE POLICE UNION SAYS THE
TEAM SHOULD STICK TO WHAT IT
KNOWS BEST AND THAT WOULD BE
FOOTBALL.
>> Jon: WAIT.
STICK TO WHAT THEY
KNOW BEST FOOTBALL?
WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE CLEVELAND BROWNS,
RIGHT?
I MEAN--
(LAUGHTER)
RANDOM CHEAP SHOT AT THE
CLEVELAND BROWNS.
LOOK, IT'S NOT AS IF THERE
ISN'T A CONVERSATION
WARRANTED ABOUT THE
CLEVELAND POLICE DEPARTMENT
BY T-SHIRT OR OTHERWISE.
>> CLEVELAND'S POLICE FORCE
HAS BEEN UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION SINCE 2013.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
EXAMINED OVER 600 CASES
>> THE CLEVELAND
DIVISION OF PUBLIC POLICE
ENGAGES IN A PATTERN AND
PRACTICE OF USING EXCESSIVE
FORCE.
>> Jon: WELL, I GUESS THE
ONLY DIFFERENCE IS WHEN
FOOTBALL PLAYERS USE
EXCESSIVE FORCE, THEY GET
PENALIZED.
AND IF THAT-- 15 YARDS, AM I
WRONG?
(LAUGHTER)
AND IF THAT FOOTBALL
PLAYER DISRESPECTED THE
OFFICER WHO SHOT AND KILLED
TAMIR RICE, A 12-YEAR-OLD
HOLD A BB GUN WITHIN 2
SECONDS OF ROLLING UP ON HIM,
YOU SHOULD HEAR WHAT THIS
OFFICER'S FORMER
EMPLOYER SAID ABOUT HIM.
>> AT HIS PREVIOUS JOB THE
INDEPENDENCE POLICE DEPARTMENT,
OFFICER LOEHMANN'S PERSONNEL
RECORDS SHOW HE WAS IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING FIRED.
HIS SUPERVISOR DESCRIBING AN
EMOTIONAL MELTDOWN.
>> ADDING THAT HE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO SUBSTANTIALLY
COPE OR MAKE GOOD DECISIONS
DURING OR RESULTING FROM ANY
OTHER STRESSFUL SITUATION.
>> BUT THE CLEVELAND POLICE
NEVER ASKED TO SEE LOEHMANN'S
PERSONNEL RECORDS.
>> Jon: EVEN WITHOUT READING
HIS RECORD, THEY SHOULD HAVE
REALIZED SOMETHING WAS WRONG
WHEN THEY MET HIM.
>> THESE BABIES CAN GO OFF.
>> Jon: SO WHY SHOULDN'T-- WHY
SHOULDN'T THE CLEVELAND
BROWNS OR ANY OTHER
CLEVELAND CITIZEN TALK ABOUT
A HUGE AND ULTIMATELY FATAL
DEPARTMENTAL SCREW UP?
>> THE CLEVELAND POLICE
UNION HEADS ARGUED ATHLETES
HAD NO BUSINESS WEIGHING IN
AT ALL SAYING QUOTE IT IS
PRETTY PATHETIC WHEN ATHLETES
THINK THEY KNOW THE LAW.
>> Jon: I GET WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM.
DUMB OLD FOOTBALL PLAYER.
I CATCH A BALL WHILE WEARING
A SHELL ON MY HEAD!
I MEAN SERIOUSLY.
WHAT MAKES THIS GUY THINK
HE'S GOT AN OPINION WORTH
SHARING ON THIS COMPLICATED
ISSUE?
AND THAT HE, THE FOOTBALL
PLAYER, SHOULDN'T APOLOGIZE.
>> MY MOMMA'S TAUGHT ME MY
ENTIRE LIFE TO RESPECT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I HAVE FAMILY, CLOSE FRIENDS
WHO ARE INCREDIBLE POLICE
OFFICERS.
AND I TELL THEM ALL THE TIME
HOW THEY ARE MUCH BRAVER
THAN ME FOR IT. UNFORTUNATELY,
MY MOM ALSO TAUGHT ME THAT
JUST AS THERE ARE GOOD
POLICE OFFICERS, THERE ARE
SOME NOT SO GOOD POLICE
OFFICERS THAT WOULD ASSUME
THE WORST OF ME WITHOUT
KNOWING ANYTHING ABOUT ME,
FOR REASONS I CAN'T CONTROL.
TO ME JUSTICE MEANS THAT THE
INNOCENT SHOULD BE FOUND
INNOCENT.
IT MEANS THAT THOSE WHO DO
WRONG SHOULD GET THEIR DUE
PUNISHMENT.
ULTIMATELY, IT MEANS FAIR
TREATMENT.
SO A CALL FOR JUSTICE
SHOULDN'T OFFEND OR
DISRESPECT ANYBODY.
A CALL FOR JUSTICE SHOULDN'T
WARRANT AN APOLOGY.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.